there it is very cool Oh fantastic could
you look any more like the Rat King in
this yeah like it doesn't even get a
shirt like that it's a hamster shirt man
your grandma's saying this shirt where
do you get a shirt like dr. rue into
that shirt I got that shirt when I was
12 years old and I've slowly grown up
and eventually one day it'll be like a
little tankini if I keep getting taller
it's got like a fortune cookie you know
you you look like you have anger
management you take it out on hamsters
like I'm hangry yeah you just slap
answers around yeah that's your therapy
too seriously though where do you get
that shirt you know cert no joke man I
got that when I was young they had them
somebody died in our area and they gave
that up and you know I was first to jump
on that piece man I love small ground
game and the second I got a chance at
that piece of just to be fully haberdash
in this piece of sweet rodentia and you
can see it if you look on the YouTube
right there and this shirt is full amp
out the front actually there's team All
Hands and actually I'm joking this shirt
is actually G Pig does guinea pig that's
a guinea pig yeah
dude it's a different game now yeah cuz
guinea pigs can take the body shot take
a nice liver shot oh yeah this is not a
liver shop yeah dude hamsters is so
small the liver shots a brain shot yeah
you don't do that you're full his fist
hits em you know yeah but a G pig
they're more built like that Daniel calm
yeah yeah they're like a little warthog
furry warthog you really unload on them
[ __ ] things there's the heavy bags of
rodents just [ __ ] hit him dude
they're beautiful yeah man sir there's a
little bit of rip my drift man I expect
you to wear this though you know like
don't you surprise me of these days yeah
I don't know like I've night if someone
asked me where you found that shirt I
could not tell you
oh that's a Pheo shirt like he might
have drew it himself and looked away
this I got a the Boy Scout I earned it
like tie knots or some [ __ ] I don't know
what they do there yeah dude tying knots
in your mama's bed sheets dude you feel
me welcome to Nottingham Robin Hood is
here why are you in sweats why are you
tapping your sweats I love you wear
sweats for one reason one reason we go
to the strip club you trying to eat that
free nut off what everyone knows that
oh dude I'll jerk off buy myself some
we're not driving Center to some
organised corporation to jerk off dude
I'd really make it hell LC and just come
at the house Papa you can come in the
club bro I'm sweat yeah you have to nut
sweat that's what we wear sweats the
only reason well I think people word
sweats on planes mal ha dude these are
action pants you delinquent that makes
sense no I couldn't find my arm I
couldn't find my wallet that's why I was
looking for either yet hamster food in
your pockets dude I'm looking for
something I lost you don't you know what
someone looks like when they're doing
that you don't know anything I don't you
bring Brendan up you see my [ __ ]
sweet ass drippy drip thing breaking
fresh off the [ __ ] Met Gala there's
that 1960s football card for your dumb
ass everyone did that receivers
quarterbacks that was the Pope leave
that snarled up rat nose I got broke bro
you look like why is my nose like that
keep zooming out of my nose I need a
goddamn nose job
can you buy me one Theo what is
happening to my nose was wrong I'm
buying me one first and second of all
dude zoom back out man you look you look
like the guy waiting for the mail at the
get a gay bathhouse bro you look like
this is you look like a mate like an all
men's mailbox you know what I'm saying
well you come dumpster no mail just mail
oh yeah they're putting that mailing you
Big Daddy huh okay you want this postman
yeah you want this - ounce package and
only deliver through the back yeah you
want these thick stamps big dog you want
that two-day delivery big dog yeah dude
you look like sprawl bunion dude like
you've gots a sprawl out on some dudes
bed in place you vote like you're about
to play fish dinner with an old man can
we go to another show you love to play
Viking freeze dag naked no oh my what is
oh is that I can fresh off the Met Gala
look at them brow look like you look
like you [ __ ] met a bunch of kids
behind a behind an Abercrombie & Fitch
right you know
well you're looking at the high schooler
that won't die bro how what grade are
you in
50th you got you came in with a hamster
sir bro
yeah cuz I look good in anything baby
because I'm the damn Rat King son and
when your mother dies and there's rats
running out of her house I'll be there
alright baby baby [ __ ] but yeah man
what are you even doing here dude dude
I'm just living what do you want
student-council bro you gotta [ __ ]
you look like a picnic like a trick Nick
dude like something that the kid that a
lot of men tender man will eat snacks
off of your back if you laid on the
ground in a park Oh like the naked sushi
girls yeah just a naked giant sushi do
ya broccolini get your life together